then taste that savory oh I don't know
what it is
hi sport Bible its major main genus on
the clumps we've been tasked with
writing the Russian scenarios of the
UK's I am NOT looking forward to this
right now I'm just Vince how what we're
doing I'm a bit worried about no idea
crackling no so I definitely know that I
was had the are flavored snacks
definitely you play that one goes on the
star quality in at midfield area Gaza
was one of one of a kind a supposed so
for me cuz it I can talk to her Gaza
maybe goes Bobby Charlton just to take
it back experience that winning a World
Cup honestly one of that great score to
do it great fire yep
I'm not sure we need to taste these I'm
definitely saying Jamie goes out I won
the champion very tail and in my life
something they never won a World Cup and
we got into a World Cup and on patriotic
and English now I'm gonna say England
for the World Cup just don't with any
finish birds do it would take would take
the chompy's need all day but it's
nonstop getting into the story to tell
the kids I suppose yeah so I'm gonna go
Spurs the Champions League okay is that
cheese oh my god consumer at the bottom
it up come on I swear the [ __ ] cooler
than your everything's the expected no
it's not
Wow what'd you expect him oh I don't
know what it is
dr filiz beat the game oh yeah I think
form is very very important experience
don't get me wrong I understand it
because too many go into a competition
even half injured not quite mr. Bailey
I'm doing the important play so I think
form players on fire yeah balance for me
both from an experienced players their
own phone even if it's a surprise
get them in there because form means
confidence and then you have to have
some experience are some other bears
take a new path so you're getting proper
what you do random real Newcastle Frey
now how are you going without
[Music]
besides I think I'm going a consolation
Russia well done if you're traveling to
Russia this summer be careful it's fair
to say right that the Russian must have
a very different taste which is you know
five years ago then well yeah all right
thanks for tribal see it a World Cup
[Music]